[Music]
in 1908 three-year-old puyi is living a
satisfactory life with his wealthy
family until one day a message changes
everything by command of the current
empress puyi's father is ordered to
bring him to the forbidden city where
the chinese emperors reside puyi's
mother seems to know something is wrong
she simply hands her son to his nurse
armo asking her to take care of him as
her own upon reaching the forbidden city
puyi and his father are presented before
the empress who is on the verge of death
she declares the boy to be the successor
and the new lord of ten thousand years
she passes away right after and a black
ball is put into her mouth sealing her
words as the absolute order little puyi
asks his father when they are returning
home but the man silently bows before
his son he's gonna have to buy him so
many toys now in the next scene puyi is
crowned as the emperor it is a crucial
ceremony for the nation but puyi being
just a kid jumps on the throne even the
highest ranking guards aren't allowed to
talk back to him so he gets away with
running around the ceremonial hall
outside thousands of officials and
servants are repeatedly bowing down to
the new emperor he stands in front of
them unable to comprehend his power at
such a young age then the kid is taken
to the bath where several officials try
to convince him to get into the tub the
kid is entertained by dancing guards
while the others bathe him there is a
group of doctors hired just to check his
stool and ensure he is eating enough poo
yi's nurse armo brings him to his
chamber and sends him to sleep while
telling him the story of how she was
appointed that sounds like a boring
story she should just put on mystery
recapped three years ago puyi's family
was hiring nurses based on their breast
milk armo is proven to have the best
breast milk among the participants since
she had just given birth to a child
after being selected she had to give up
her child forever to take care of puyi
and to make a better life for herself
the scene cuts to 42 years in the future
on the chinese-russian border a train
carrying war criminals comes to a halt
and many prisoners are hustled into the
station then four prisoners suddenly get
up and bow down in front of another
criminal they treat him as god but the
man seems uncomfortable receiving their
praise when the criminals are taken away
he goes to the bathroom and commits the
unthinkable soon the governor comes
looking for the man and starts banging
on the door upon getting no reply as the
man watches the sink fill with his blood
it is then revealed that he is none
other than the last emperor of china
puyi the attempt fails when the governor
finds puyi and saves his life after that
all war criminals are brought to a
public security detention center in
fushoon while being assigned to rooms
puyi meets his blood brother poochie
the scene then changes back to 1914. it
has been almost seven years since puyi's
crowning and his family has come to meet
him for the first time the parents leave
shortly but not before leaving their
younger son poochier with puyi initially
poochie takes time to adjust to the
royal environment puyi helps him by
boasting about how other people get
punished for his mistakes and how he is
allowed to do anything he pleases this
is proven when he breastfeeds off armo
at the age of 10 and no one bats an eye
just because you can get away with a
thing doesn't mean you should do it
later the brothers get into an argument
when puyi degrades pouchier for wearing
yellow which is a color only the emperor
can wear inside the palace in
retaliation poutier reveals that he is
not the emperor anymore puyi tries to
discredit him and asks the guard to
drink green ink when the guard does is
told he thinks his point is proven but
puccier remains adamant in his claims he
leads puyi to the top of a newly
constructed wall built to divide the
northern residential section from the
rest of the forbidden city they see a
man riding in a car below with several
guards around him like he is the emperor
puyi is shaken at the threat being made
to his throne he asks the high tudor if
he is still emperor and is told that he
will always be the emperor inside the
forbidden city but not outside because
china is now a republic and the
legitimate ruler is the president
another shock hits puyi when he
discovers his dear armo has been sent
away because he doesn't need a nurse
anymore we see the guards forcefully
carrying her out of the palace refusing
to let her meet puyi to say the last
goodbye the scene cuts to 1950 again
puyi and puccia are imprisoned as war
criminals in the same cell the governor
berates all the prisoners for betraying
their country in the time of war
ordering them to write down every
mistake they have made and crimes they
have committed in life back in 1919 a
tutor named johnston is assigned to
educate 15 year old puyi he discovers
that puji is a spoiled entitled kid who
doesn't know the value of hard work with
time he wins the kid's trust by
providing him news from the outside that
he isn't allowed to be exposed to he
even gifts puyi a pair of sunglasses and
fights the superior lord chamberlain to
let the kid wear them three years pass
and in 1922 puyi is asked to marry wan
zhang a princess who matches his
standard when puyi retaliates that he
wants to marry someone of his choice he
is given the freedom to choose his
second wife i'll take it says puyi after
the first wedding ceremony he gets to
see juan's face and is mesmerized by her
beauty she covers his face with kisses
while the servants who are also in the
room take their clothes off however juan
stops them midway and they ultimately
decide to sleep without making love
again back to the future puyi is taken
to a room and asked to reveal why he
thinks he's in prison as a criminal his
first response implies that he is an
innocent man who was pulled into life as
an emperor and has no part in china's
recent history the interrogator angrily
refuses to take the answer so the former
emperor starts telling him what happened
in 1923. by now he is old enough to rule
the way he pleases and not under adults
who exploited their power first he cuts
off the woven ponytail which until
recently was considered a crime against
the nation he then demands audits of the
expenses done by the imperial storerooms
that night the officials burn the audits
to keep their corruption hidden but the
next day puyi expels all of them with
the help of republican troops the
interrogator wants to know how puyi
connected with the japanese it turns out
that in the war he sided with japan
which is why he is considered a national
criminal puji continues that when he was
19 he and the imperial family were
attacked by the troops of the warlord
thang they are given one hour to leave
the forbidden city puyi has not been out
of the palace since he was three so the
family has absolutely nowhere to go at
such time johnston suggests they take
asylum in the british embassy for the
first time in 16 years puyi leaves his
home and as they depart the republican
flag is raised over the forbidden city
however unlike what they had decided the
imperials go to the japanese embassy
because it is prepared to help puyi
argues that he did not ask them for
support but aided himself by selling
family treasures puyi then remembers the
time he was in tient sin he and his
first wife juan have changed their names
to henry and elizabeth they're enjoying
themselves at a party where puyi's
second wife siu is dancing with an
american they get a little too close
while talking about puyi's wives as they
drive to the japanese location after the
party cu declares that she wants a
divorce a shocked puyi retaliates that
no one can divorce him but siu leaves
shortly after never to return later that
night puyi's distant cousin jewel
arrives at their residence and meets
elizabeth while getting high on opium
she reveals that she is a japanese spy
an innocent elizabeth trusts her but
still shares her worries about puyi and
his relationship with the japanese she
is not happy that he sent his brother to
a military academy in tokyo later puyi
is informed about the recent vandalism
of their ancestors tombs by the troops
of the nationalist party in the present
puyi is asked if he joined hands with
the japanese in their transformation of
the chinese city of manchuria into a
japanese puppet state manchukuo puyi
insists that he has no hand in
manchuria's politics and that he was
kidnapped and taken to the city the
governor knows the truth is far from
what huyi is saying he proves his point
by reading a line from johnston's book
where he has clearly stated the story
about being kidnapped is a lie and that
puyi had a huge role in the
transformation of manchuria when he
still insists otherwise he is left alone
then he recalls what actually happened
surrounding his kidnapping in 1932 the
japanese are using puyi's hereditary
right to rule manchuria but he in turn
wishes to use them to come back into
power johnston knows what puyi is doing
is not ethical but puyi shows his
spoiled and arrogant side once again
claiming that china has turned its back
on him now it is his turn to do the same
his wish comes true in 1934 when the
japanese decide to promote puyi to be
emperor of manchukuo now that he has
served as head of state for the past two
years he yet again gets to wear the
traditional robes of the king dynasty
that he took so much pride in jewel who
is also at the ceremony congratulates
elizabeth telling her that she is an
empress again then we are introduced to
emma casu an order in the imperial
japanese army and puyi's close work
friend he snaps photos of elizabeth and
jewel together he even supervises the
filming at the coronation ball that
evening meanwhile pouchier is also at
the party in a japanese military uniform
with his pregnant wife as the lively
party continues elizabeth and jewell
arrive high on opium since she is not in
her right mind elizabeth embarrasses
herself by eating daffodils from a
flower arrangement that's not
embarrassing that's funny as hell when
puyi confronts her elizabeth makes fun
of him claiming that amakasu is the most
powerful man in manchukuo they also
argue about their sex life and how he
doesn't make love to her anymore to stop
the heated argument elizabeth makes a
toast to him and walks out of the party
back in the prison puji continues living
like an emperor bullying his cellmates
to teach him a lesson the governor puts
him in a cell with people who are bound
to humble him in the new cell puji is
asked to do chores that he has never
done in his life the people who order
him are all government officials in
manchukuo puyi is ordered to pee quietly
in a bucket to refrain from disturbing
his cellmates it is the lowest he has
ever been treated he looks at his former
valet for some kind of reassurance but
the man surprises him by asking if he
really thinks he is still a servant puyi
is finally on the receiving side of how
he has been treating people until now
then in 1935 puyi returns from a trip to
tokyo and finds several changes have
been made to his government waiting for
him in the palace are colonel yoshioka
and amikazu the colonel has disarmed the
imperial guards and even puyi's prime
minister has moved away to a monastery
in the hills it is clear that it is a
ruse to get puyi out of power but he has
no way to retaliate in the following
council meeting he is asked to sign
papers that would appoint defence
minister chang as the new prime minister
this would directly mean the end of his
rule so he refuses to sign as a result
all the council members leave the
meeting portraying their dissatisfaction
when alone in the council room puyi is
taken back to the day he found out he
was no longer the legitimate emperor
later that day elizabeth announces her
pregnancy but before puyi can react they
are interrupted by colonel yoshioka and
emmakasu they want him to sign the
papers he refused to sign in the meeting
earlier puyi deflects the topic by
announcing that he is to have an heir
but is informed by a pass of emikasu
that the father of the child is his
driver at last puyi has no way out but
to appoint chang as the prime minister
in the following scene we see puyi shoot
his driver dad for seducing his wife
little peepee energy to be sure a few
months later elizabeth gives birth but
the doctor murders the baby puyi is told
the child was stillborn elizabeth runs
away from the hospital never to return
leaving puyi alone then in 1945 the
japanese emperor surrenders and the war
is over jules listens to the surrender
broadcast while amakasu commits the
unthinkable elizabeth also comes back
from hiding and is over the moon because
of amakasi's death she spits in the face
of the japanese soldiers mocking them
when she comes across her ex-husband she
shakes in shock and has to be aided by
her nurse meanwhile colonel yoshioka is
trying to run back to japan to escape
the russian soldiers he wants puyi to
join him but the man delays trying to
get to his wife first she refuses to
come and eventually puyi and the colonel
are caught this is how they were
imprisoned for five years before being
brought to the prison poo yi is
currently in back in the present puyi is
tending to his flower garden in the
prison after years of spending time with
the inmates as equals he has found a
passion for gardening his rivalry with
the governor has also died down and they
seem to like each other now the governor
laughs at the fact that all his life
puyi thought he was better than everyone
else but now he thinks he is the worst
of all which is why he tried to commit
the unthinkable then comes the year 1959
when puyi is handed a proclamation of
release after serving 14 years in prison
he has happily let go of the place to
live an entirely new life the scene cuts
to the year 1967 the former emperor now
works as a gardener at beijing botanical
gardens and is leading a decent life one
afternoon he visits the forbidden city
and looks at his former throne as his
heart fills with emotions he steps over
the decorative rope beyond which the
tourists are not allowed to go a boy
stops him and puyi replies that he was
the emperor of china when the boy is
distracted puyi disappears and is never
found in the last scene a tour guide
leads tourists into the throne room
telling them about puyi's life story and
explaining that he died in 1967.
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching